I mean he was in the bathroom for two
hours yeah but so are you but you're
[__] yeah but not every
morning
what if you didn't have your phone how
much less time would you be in the
bathroom probably a good amount
50% yeah probably somewhere on there are
you scrolling on the [__] are you
replying to people uh I'm doing a little
bit of both like I I always look at the
the the notifications to see what I had
for like post or whatnot so I can
respond but then a lot of the times I
just get lost in Tik Tok can I tell you
if I text I just straight up lose track
of time if I text you from the toilet I
I sign it from the [__] I want you to
know as you're reading
this that I'm pooping I haven't gotten
that one yet from you no you haven't
gotten from the [__] but I I for sure
have gotten text from you while you were
pooping yeah but the last one I just
said I'm pooping so I didn't have to say
I'm from the [__] you didn't say you
were pooping you sent me a picture of
you [__] kidding yourself that's how I
knew you were pooping oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I did that too but that was a
little while ago guys I don't want you
to think that happens all the time but
it did happen a few weeks back it does
it happens a lot it doesn't happen a lot
why would you say a lot I'm not going to
lie I jinxed myself earlier and talking
about pooping is making me have to poop
so I'm going to wait a couple more
minutes well what time did we start how
long I know this is like how much time
it was like it was like four minutes in
when we started so we're can you can you
wait eight minutes yeah what if I just
start
going you just see me walk out and you
might have to close the podcast
out I don't know what that sound is I
don't
either that's not what it sounds like
when I poop everybody I want you to know
is that the sound your [__]
[Music]
makes I don't even know what that noise
is why would I it's not like the sound
of P makes me want to pee the sound of
to poop doesn't make me it's the
thinking about pooping that's where I'm
at right now cuz we were talking about
it a lot and I jinxed myself earlier and
now we're going to see how long I can
last and we both know that nothing makes
you need to poop more than pulling into
the driveway at your house and there's
no way I'm going to do that oh dude that
if you if by the time you pull in if
sometimes I don't know I got a poop and
then I pull into my driveway I'm like
well I'm going to [__] in the car yeah
or on the lawn this is about to happen
yeah yeah I have pooped on the lawn and
in a shoe box um
um in the shoe box on the side of the
house tell me oh is it really getting
close oh it's creeping up are you
clenching your not right now it right
now not right now uh when it gets to
that point I do but also I feel like
sometimes if you do it too much like
your your body just eventually is going
to give out so like I so sometimes
sometimes when I'm clenching I feel like
I actually Tire the muscles correct and
so sometimes when it settles I let it
relax a little bit until I get to a
point to where I can't it's like it's
like doing keegel yeah it's like I'm
doing reps legit I might you know what
I'm gonna do a little test you're going
to hold your poop so much for the next
month anytime I fly I'm going to do
butthole kles for 10 minutes and I'm
going to see but just with the clenching
and the holding and then the releasing
and so I'm G to see if it if it if my if
my butthole muscles get stronger I'm not
going to lie that's a great way to end
this podcast because I don't I don't
know how to follow that up ladies and
gentlemen but guys by the way I'm going
to Google butth hole kles and the
correct way to do them I'm not just
going to go on willy-nilly you know me I
don't think you're going to get the
right videos you want I think butth
holek keagle the
correct uh way to do them Dr Kang taught
me you just ask Dr Kang what yeah I was
why did Dr Kang talk to you about I said
there was one time I was having like
kind of lower back pain but also some
some sphincter pain and I was like like
sometimes it just felt like like a cramp
almost I was like what is that he goes
you have a weak butthole and I was
like okay um I was like I was like I
don't I don't know how I'm supposed to
feel about that thank you I guess wait
and so he was like so he was like so you
have to try sometimes sitting just like
straight up knees together and you have
to do keegle
exercises Dr King told you you had a
weak butthole he did he did Dr K did
tell me I had a weak
butthole I don't know if that's a good
thing or not might
be on that note ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much for stopping by I've
been Jacob wolf that's been Josh Wolf
comedian Josh wolf.com for Tates and
tickets we're going to be in a sitting
near you